yes i was a train robber and a bank
robber
that was back in 1895 six and seven
it was after my brother had been
murdered the lord failed
to convict the murders and i went out
for revenge
and got myself tangled up in a business
way with some other people
and we went into train robin bank
robbing just as a business like any
other businessman would
the last train robbery that i was
engaged in with my band of bandits
was on the rock island it was the meteor
at 11
50 11 55 a.m
we all knew there was a hundred thousand
dollars on there
that was to pay the indians a friend
gave us that tip
we stopped it at 11 55
at pocasset and we were there about an
hour
some of the details of the robbery might
be amusing and some of it's serious
i knew there was a hundred thousand
dollars in the express
and we intended to get that but we
couldn't open the safe and we blew the
car nearly to pieces
then i'm not getting any money i ordered
the passengers out on the right away and
lined them up against them
the the wire fence and then we took up
our offering from them it was during
that time
that i recognized many of my old friends
that i'd known when i was county
attorney in el reno
but they didn't know me because i had
wore i wore a mask that day
many prominent lawyers preachers were on
the train
some of them i knew well i wore a mask
on that occasion because
i was not afraid of identification but i
was ashamed of my calling and i didn't
want my old friends to know the line of
business i was engaged in
then it was that they finally captured
me
put me in the hands of a receiver at
columbus ohio for the period of my
natural life at hard labor it was during
that time that i had
to reflect on the past and then it was
the regrets came
and i stepped onto the penitentiary door
due to the fact that senator mark hanna
procured my liberty
through william mckinley afterwards
theodore roosevelt gave me a full and
free pardon
and his confidence i promised him i'd
make good
i have been honest for over 30 years
but very lonesome but i want it
understood but the voice of the land
that it doesn't pay really and truly to
be abandoned
i don't think it pays to violate the law
in any sense
i hope under circumstances by speaking
to the public
that i may in some small way assist
the better understanding of law
enforcement i have no reference to
prohibition
i speak of the law in general and now i
want to say for the benefit of the boys
of the land
don't rob anybody don't think of
violating the law
i want you to realize that all the
misery and the heartache
that was incident to those days of
outlawing
come back to me like a cruel shadow
i want to see the law enforced i want
the law to be enforced honestly on
all alike in this land of ours so that
every
void now growing up under its influence
can have respect
and will obey the law instead of being
thrown into a vortex
that we have now like the crime
commission is trying to suppress
i want to see your boys going to schools
and to colleges
growing up to be men and not bandits
but if they've got to violate the law
let them become
uh wait and become candidates for public
office
they can get it so much easier and not
be caught
i thank you very much
[Music]
do
you